this is my home i made a promise
to protect it me and this family
can't break it i won't betray you
you have my word i'm about to find out
what that's worth
market equities is building an airport
and then they're going to build a city
around it
it's called economic evolution you are
sealing yourself into the alamo these
guys won't take prisoners either
hey i want you to give john dutton a
message for me
and just like that seven generations of
our family legacy will be taken from you
this valley is mine come and get it
i plan to this is survival
kill or be killed you leave now
or you'll never leave you know what they
say about making deals with the devil
this genie does not go back in the
bottom
i think you're up for this fight beth
you have no idea how wrong you are you
are the trailer park
i am the tornado
destiny's a hard thing to run from
you're all i need
there's monsters everywhere in this
world
[Music]
we keep our ward in this valley and
don't you ever be sorry for it
you